[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt!
Der Überschrift des Videos habt ihr ja schon entnommen:
Heute geht es um das Thema Brot backen.
Es gibt ja auf meinem Kanal schon einige Brotbackrezepte.
Es gibt das Brot ohne Kneten,
das magische Baguette ohne Kneten.
Aber ich habe zum Beispiel auch aufwendigere Brote
mit selbst gemachter Hefe,
wo einfach der Brotteig mehrere Tage lang geführt wird,
angerührt wird und dann eben gebacken wird.
Es haben sich aber auch ganz viele Menschen gewünscht,
dass ich mal einfache Brotrezepte mache.
Und ich muss persönlich auch dazu sagen,
dass ich das Brotbacken wirklich sehr mag und sehr liebe,
aber ich habe zum Beispiel keine Zeit,
einen Sauerteig anzusetzen, den zu führen, zu füttern.
Ich meine, ich habe ja schon Samira und Ela zu füttern
und Murat auch,
meine drei Kinder.
Und deswegen ist bei mir zum Beispiel so ein Sauerteig,
echt muss ich sagen,
es wird bei mir stiefmütterlich behandelt.
Also ich habe es auch schon mal angesetzt,
aber der wurde mir dann doch wieder schlecht,
weil ich eben die Zeit nicht dazu habe im Alltag.
Also kam uns irgendwann die Idee:
Machen wir doch einfach Brotvormischungen.
Und wir haben da einen ganz lieben Freund, den Peter.
Und zwar ist es eine Odenwälder Mühle,
ein Familienunternehmen.
Und die Firma Seitz macht für uns jetzt
praktisch unsere eigenen Brotvormischungen.
Brotvormischung bedeutet:
Wir haben uns einfach sechs Sorten Brot ausgesucht,
haben die zusammengestellt, haben überlegt:
Wie sollen die schmecken? Wie sollen sie aussehen?
Was kann man dafür tun?
Und haben uns dann überlegt: Okay, so machen wir es.
Brotvormischung bedeutet:
Ich habe dann feinste Mehle, Saaten, Körner,
Gewürze und Kräuter zusammengepackt
und im Prinzip vorportioniert,
sodass ihr einfach einen Beutel voll
mit einer Brotvormischung habt
und das Ganze dann nur noch mit Hefe
und mit Wasser anrühren müsst.
Und so habt ihr dann am Ende eine dieser sechs Brotsorten.
Und ich denke, gerade so für den Alltag
ist es wirklich eine ziemliche Erleichterung,
weil wir auch in den Brotvormischungen
teilweise Sauerteig mit drin haben,
also einen getrockneten Sauerteig.
Ich habe die Brote so ausgewählt,
dass wirklich jedes Brot ganz individuell schmeckt,
ganz anders schmeckt
und einfach eine andere Besonderheit hat.
Und was mir dabei auch wichtig ist,
dass wirklich jeder die Brote zu Hause selbst machen kann,
ohne großes Werkzeug,
ohne einen ganz besonderen Backofen.
Ich gebe euch in diesem Video auch Tipps und Tricks,
wie ihr die Teige verarbeitet,
wie ihr die Brote formt,
wie ihr einen Gärkorb benutzt,
aber auch das Brot ohne Gärkorb backen könnt,
wie ihr das Brot mit dem Dampfbackofen am besten backt,
aber wie es eben auch ohne Dampfbackofen
und ohne einen Gusseisentopf geht.
Also dieses Video ist wirklich vollgepackt
mit vielen Informationen, vielen Zubereitungsmöglichkeiten.
Und ihr seht ja auch schon hier
anhand dieser Brote, die hier vor mir liegen,
dass es wirklich total vielfältig ist.
Was ich dazu sagen muss:
Also die Brotbackmischungen
– es sind ja keine Backmischungen,
wo alles Drum und Dran drin ist.
Ihr bestimmt ja im Prinzip den Hefegehalt auch selbst,
fügt noch das Wasser hinzu.
Man kann diese Brotvormischung
nicht mit einer Brotbackmischung
aus dem Supermarkt vergleichen.
Also wir haben jetzt wirklich ganz viele hochwertige Zutaten,
die die Firma Seitz eben für uns zusammenmischt.
Und die Firma beliefert ja auch
die ganzen handwerklichen Bäcker.
Und da muss ich echt dazu sagen,
dass ich das Bäckerhandwerk
gerade bei uns hier in Deutschland sehr lobe,
weil wirklich so viel Handarbeit drinnen steckt,
so viel Liebe drinnen steckt,
viele hochwertige Zutaten.
Und ich finde es echt schade,
wenn man zum Supermarkt läuft
und sich das Brot aus dem Automaten zieht.
Weil ich denke:
Wenn ihr schon Brot kauft,
dann kauft es wirklich bei eurem Bäcker vor Ort,
unterstützt den Handwerksbetrieb.
Und ich will jetzt auch mit diesem Video nicht sagen:
"Macht euer Brot in Zukunft nur noch selber",
sondern wirklich unterstützt ruhig die Bäcker vor Ort weiter.
Ich kenne auch ganz viele tolle Brotbäcker
wie zum Beispiel die Brotpuristen in Speyer,
die ihr Brot selbst machen,
Julius Brantner in München.
Den habe ich auch schon besucht.
Und gerade mit Brotpuristen
– die sind ja hier wirklich regional aus meiner Ecke –
wollte ich auch schon zusammen was machen.
Das machen wir auch.
Aber ich will damit echt nur sagen:
Das Brothandwerk ist wirklich
eine richtig hohe Kunst des Backens,
wirklich was ganz, ganz Tolles, was unterstützt werden muss.
Und wir wollen das Ganze
im Prinzip nur ein bisschen bereichern,
sodass ihr zu Hause eben auch hochwertiges Brot
mit tollen Zutaten eben selbst zubereiten könnt.
Ich stelle euch jetzt mal einzeln ganz kurz die Brote vor.
Wir starten jetzt hier bei der Nummer eins.
Wir haben uns auch wirklich von Anfang bis zum Schluss,
also nicht nur bei den Zutaten,
sondern auch bei der Verpackung
ganz viele Gedanken gemacht.
Denn ich habe mir gedacht,
ich möchte eine Verpackung machen,
die eben keinen Müll schafft,
sodass wir hier unsere Brotvormischung
in diese braune Kraftpapiertüten gepackt haben.
Wir haben hier diesen Flyer obendrauf gemacht.
Das heißt, wenn ihr die Brotbackmischung,
Brotvormischung verwendet,
habt ihr wirklich auch noch einen Beutel,
den ihr weiter benutzen könnt,
um zum Beispiel Kekse oder Cookies zu verpacken
oder euer belegtes Brot einfach mit zur Arbeit mitzunehmen.
Ich fange jetzt hier an bei der Nummer eins.
Wir haben uns wirklich gedacht,
wir nummerieren die Brote jetzt einfach.
Denn ich tue mich ganz schwer damit,
zu sagen: "Okay, das ist jetzt ein Sonntagsbrot.
Das ist ein Winzerbrot.
Das ist das Kraftbrot."
Deswegen, haben wir gesagt,
nummerieren wir sie einfach.
Und jedes Brot hat seine Besonderheit
und die erfahrt ihr jetzt.
Brot Nummer eins, muss ich sagen,
dazu gibt es eine ganz besondere Geschichte.
Wir waren letztes Jahr in unserem allerallerersten Urlaub
und zwar auf Sansibar in Ostafrika.
Und in Ostafrika gibt es richtig tolle Getreidesorten,
zum Beispiel Hirse oder auch Teff.
Und wir haben dort ganz gerne beim Frühstück
oder auch abends so zu den Soßen
und zu den ganz tollen Eintöpfen dazu
gerne die Fladenbrote dort gegessen,
weil gerade Hirse und auch Teff
wirklich ganz nährstoffreiche Getreidesorten sind.
Und so kamen wir eigentlich dazu,
dass wir gesagt haben, wir machen ein Brot,
was uns so ein bisschen an unsere Afrikareise erinnert.
Deswegen haben wir hier Brot Nummer eins.
Also hier seht ihr mal die Hauptzutaten.
Ich habe hier zum einen das Weizenmehl,
ein Roggenmehl,
Roggenmalzmehl,
Teffmehl.
Dann habe ich hier noch ganz viele besondere Zutaten,
wie zum Beispiel Sonnenblumenkerne,
Sesam,
Hirse,
Leinsamen
und Sojaschrot.
Hier habe ich noch Haferkleie
und natürlich Salz.
Weizen und Roggen sind natürlich
hier auch Hauptbestandteile,
aber wir haben ja auch hier eben das Roggenmalzmehl,
was die schöne dunkle Farbe mit dazu bringt
und einfach so einen kräftigen Geschmack.
Ich habe hier die Haferkleie,
die eben das Wasser schön bindet,
und das Brot bleibt dadurch auch richtig schön lang feucht.
Und Hafer hat natürlich einen hohen Ballaststoffanteil.
Daher haben wir hier die Haferkleie mit dabei.
Die Zutaten, die ihr hier seht,
gerade so die Sonnenblumenkerne,
der Sesam,
aber auch die Hirse und der Sojaschrot,
die dienen dazu, dass die Krume innen
wirklich schön zum einen ein schönes Schnittbild ergibt.
Also, wenn man das Brot aufschneidet,
hat man einfach ein wunderwunderschönes Bild.
Aber es dient auch der Konsistenzgebung.
Denn, wenn ihr das Brot dann beißt und esst,
dann habt ihr einfach die Sonnenblumenkerne mit dabei,
die Hirse mit dabei, die Leinsamen natürlich auch.
Und das, finde ich, muss ich sagen,
gibt dem ganzen Brot natürlich die ganz besondere Note.
Und im Prinzip sind es wirklich Zutaten,
die superhochwertig sind
und die man, wenn man jetzt das Brot
alleine zu Hause ohne Backvormischung machen möchte
– ist natürlich schwierig,
weil man nicht so viele Zutaten eben auf Vorrat hat.
Deswegen haben wir uns hier gedacht:
Komm, machen wir hier dieses Afrika-inspirierte Brot für euch.
Und ich würde euch jetzt einfach mal kurz zeigen,
wie man das Brot zubereitet.
Denn es ist wirklich supereinfach.
Ihr habt praktisch diese Zutaten abgepackt
hier in unserem Beutel
und müsst dann nur noch warmes Wasser
und eben Hefe dazu geben.
Das machen wir jetzt geschwind zusammen.
Vielleicht machen wir jetzt ganz kurz einen Hefeexkurs.
Und zwar gibt es bei Hefe,
die man im Supermarkt kaufen kann,
ganz viele verschiedene Qualitäten.
Und ich weiß, dass die Hefe,
die meine Mutter immer benutzt hat,
einfach so aussah.
Das heißt, die Hefe, wenn man sie zerbröckelt,
dann bröckelt sie eben auch.
Ihr seht das hier, schön trocken.
Und mittlerweile ist mir aber auch aufgefallen:
Es gibt Hefe, die so aussieht,
und die ist halt komplett nass, also wie Knete.
Guckt mal. Die kann man echt total verkneten.
Da könnt ihr jetzt euch eine Figur daraus formen.
Guckt. Zack, zack, zack.
Ich wollte es euch nur zeigen.
Und bei der Hefe ist das Problem,
dass die einfach vollgesaugt ist mit Wasser.
Und die hat nicht die Triebkraft,
die eine Hefe eigentlich haben sollte.
Was ihr jetzt tun könnt:
Ihr könnt entweder mal gucken,
ob ihr im Supermarkt eine gute Hefe findet,
oder ihr geht zum Beispiel zum Bäcker eures Vertrauens
einfach vor Ort und könnt dort fragen,
ob ihr dort Backhefe, also Bäckerhefe abkaufen könnt.
Das machen sie auch generell eigentlich ganz gerne.
Vielleicht solltet ihr nicht nur die Hefe kaufen,
sondern auch einen Kuchen oder ein Brot oder Brötchen.
Und dann könnt ihr euch wirklich so einen Block Hefe kaufen
und habt dann auch wirklich eine Hefe,
die eine tolle Triebeigenschaft hat.
Ich friere Hefe ja auch ganz gerne mal ein,
gerade so für Hefekuchen
oder für Buchteln oder für Nusszopf.
Man muss aber sagen:
Wenn man die Hefe aus dem Gefrierfach nimmt,
dann verliert sie auch ihre Triebkraft,
was jetzt bei mir bei einem Hefekuchen nicht schlimm wäre,
weil ich dann einfach einen kompletten Würfel nehme
statt der Hälfte.
Aber beim Brotbacken sollte man das auf jeden Fall beachten.
Und die Hefe, die ihr beim Bäcker bekommt,
die ist auch drei Wochen im Kühlschrank haltbar.
Ihr müsst sie einfach luftdicht verpacken,
in Folie einwickeln, damit sie nicht austrocknet,
und könnt dann eben die Hefe für das Brot benutzen.
Wir hätten natürlich auch im Brot Hefe mit einarbeiten können,
in der Brotvormischung.
Aber wir haben gesagt: Jeder möchte ja auch vielleicht
eine andere Hefemenge benutzen.
Also angegeben habe ich es als halben Würfel,
das heißt 21 Gramm Hefe.
Und damit könnt ihr dann
im Prinzip das Brot relativ schnell backen.
Wenn ihr sagt, ihr möchtet eher eine Übernachtgare,
– und das gilt jetzt wirklich für alle sechs Sorten –
könnt ihr die 21 Gramm auch noch mal halbieren
und sagen, ihr setzt den Teig an
und könnt zum Beispiel für sonntagmorgens
eben Brötchen machen
und den Teig dann mit der halben Hefemenge zubereiten,
im Kühlschrank lagern
und dann kann er eben länger gehen.
Das hat natürlich auch den Vorteil,
dass das Brot bekömmlicher wird.
Manche Menschen mögen ja auch gar nicht so viel Hefe.
Aber ich muss sagen: Für die 750 Gramm Mehl
sind die 21 Gramm Hefe für mich,
für meine Verhältnisse auf jeden Fall sehr gut,
weil es wirklich eine recht geringe Menge ist.
Okay.
Also ich bereite es jetzt hier einmal zu
mit der richtig schönen Bäckerhefe
und nicht mit der feuchten Hefe.
Ihr könnt aber
– ich habe es auch schon mit der Supermarkthefe ausprobiert.
Klappt auch wunderbar.
Also...
Und ihr könnt auch Trockenhefe nehmen,
also statt 21 Gramm frischer Hefe
einfach einen Beutel Trockenhefe.
Was ich jetzt hier machen werde
– im Prinzip steht auch alles auf der Verpackung.
Aber für euch im Video jetzt:
Einmal den Beutel hier aufschneiden.
Und ihr seht jetzt auch hier schon:
Jetzt habt ihr hier praktisch die zwei Karten
mit der Vorder- und Rückseite.
Der einzige Müll, der dabei entsteht, ist das hier.
Und wir haben auch wirklich
auf eine komplett plastikfreie Verpackung geachtet.
Und was ihr jetzt tut, ist im Prinzip,
die Backvormischung,
also die guten Mehle, die Saaten und die Gewürze
mit der Hefe und der richtigen Wassermenge
– die Wassermenge steht natürlich auch mit drauf.
Die ändert sich natürlich von Brotvormischung
zu Brotvormischung.
Denn jedes Mehl nimmt ja auch
eine andere Wassermenge auf.
Ich werde das Ganze jetzt
hier mit der Küchenmaschine verkneten.
Ihr könnt den Teig auch gerne mit der Hand verkneten,
aber ihr müsst eben darauf achten,
dass ihr mindestens 10 bis 15 Minuten knetet.
Und bei der Küchenmaschine habt ihr eben den Vorteil,
dass ihr eine schöne Spannung auf den Teig bekommt.
Das heißt, je mehr ihr knetet, umso besser wird das Brot,
umso größer wird die Porung,
umso stabiler wird eben das Konstrukt,
was man eben auch mit den Mehlen erzeugen möchte.
Deswegen empfehle ich es.
Aber, wenn ihr sagt, ihr habt keine Küchenmaschine,
dann knetet einfach fleißig.
Macht halt auch gute Oberarme.
Und vielleicht könnt ihr euch ja euren Mann
oder euren Freund oder die Freundin
– wenn sie stärker ist als ihr, kann sie ja kneten.
Ich würde den Murat kneten lassen.
Dann hat er was zu tun und macht keinen Unsinn.
Ich werde jetzt trotzdem erst mal die Hefe hier reingeben.
Kurz das Wasser dazu
direkt abwiegen.
[Musik]
Jetzt kurz bei niedriger Stufe verrühren
und dann wirklich für etwa zehn Minuten schön verkneten.
Was ich hier auch ganz schön finde
– also wir haben uns wirklich
von Anfang bis zum Ende Gedanken gemacht.
Und ich habe gesagt:
Ich möchte nicht Verpackungsmüll verursachen.
Und deswegen könnt ihr zum Beispiel diesen Beutel,
der ja jetzt unbedruckt ist,
könnt ihr einfach weiter benutzen
und zum Beispiel Kekse verpacken und verschenken.
[Musik]
Jetzt ist der Teig fertig geknetet.
So sieht er aus, richtig schön.
Also ich finde, gerade das erste Brot,
das hat halt so für mich die schönste Farbe,
so ganz, ganz besonders.
Und der Teig, der sollte jetzt auf jeden Fall ruhen.
Also ihr seht auch schon,
der klebt noch so ein bisschen an den Fingern.
Aber jetzt bitte gar kein Mehl dazuarbeiten,
sondern der Teig muss jetzt erst mal quellen.
Das heißt, ich gebe ihn hier auf meine Arbeitsplatte.
Wenn ihr eine Silikonmatte habt,
müsst ihr die jetzt nicht bemehlen.
Aber, wenn ihr eine andere Unterlage habt,
ein Holzbrett oder so,
dann auf jeden Fall ein bisschen Mehl drauf geben.
Schön alles auskratzen.
Das macht man nicht nur in Schwaben so,
das macht man überall so.
Und wie gesagt, jetzt ist er ein bisschen klebrig,
wie ihr sehen könnt.
Aber der wird jetzt einfach abgedeckt
und darf etwa 20 Minuten ruhen.
So geht er zum einen ein bisschen auf
und, wie gesagt, das Wasser wird gebunden.
Und dann können wir ihn gleich weiter verarbeiten.
Und in der Zeit könnt ihr schon mal aufräumen.
[Musik]
So. So sieht der Teig jetzt aus.
Und jetzt könnt ihr ihn formen, also aufarbeiten.
Das heißt, das Brot bekommt jetzt seine Form.
Ihr könnt es jetzt entweder rund machen
oder ein Baguette daraus formen,
ein Wurzelbrot machen.
Also da schaut ihr einfach, was euch am besten gefällt.
Und ich nehme jetzt hier natürlich ein bisschen Mehl.
Und da muss ich jetzt also die Hände leicht bemalen.
Den Teig könnt ihr jetzt formen
und in einem Gärkorb aufgehen lassen
oder einfach hier direkt auf einem Backblech aufgehen lassen.
Also das dient einfach der Formgebung.
Was ihr jetzt nicht machen solltet, ist viel Mehl reinkneten.
Und jetzt im Prinzip so von außen nach innen,
sodass er wirklich, wenn ihr ihn umdreht,
dann eine schöne, glatte Oberfläche hat.
Und da jetzt auch nicht zu viel kneten.
Denn ansonsten reißt er an der Oberfläche.
Also so reicht es wirklich schon.
Und arbeitet da wirklich nicht vorne mit den Fingerspitzen,
sondern mit dem Handballen,
also immer mit dem Handballen
und dann kriegt ihr echt eine schöne Form hin.
Wie gesagt, nehme ich jetzt ein Gärkörbchen.
Ich bekomme ja daraus ein Kilo Brot.
Ihr könnt jetzt ein großes machen oder zwei kleine,
falls ihr das Brot zum Beispiel auch teilen wollt,
und könnt jetzt hier das Gärkörbchen
einfach ein bisschen mehlen.
Und dann mit der glatten Seite nach unten reinlegen.
Und so darf das jetzt noch mal aufgehen.
Ich werde es natürlich auch abdecken
und noch mal stehen lassen.
Was ihr alternativ nehmen könnt,
wenn ihr kein Gärkörbchen habt
– ich denke, es funktioniert auch.
Ihr könnt auch ein Haarsieb nehmen,
ein Tuch reinlegen und das Brot hier reinlegen.
Das wäre so die Alternative.
Aber so ein Gärkörbchen hat halt schon viele Vorteile,
zumal man eben die Form richtig schön perfekt hinbekommt.
Aber wie gesagt, geht es auch ohne.
Ihr könnt auch das Brot einfach auf ein Tuch legen
und so eben aufgehen lassen.
Das hat mehr optische Gründe natürlich auch.
Ich lasse es jetzt noch mal kurz aufgehen.
Und dann wird es gleich gebacken.
Also ihr seht, das Brotbacken ist echt supereinfach.
Ich habe einmal den Teig geknetet,
jetzt geformt.
Im Prinzip habt ihr einfach nur die Wartezeit
und die ist auch nicht so lang.
Ja.
Der Teig ist jetzt aufgegangen.
Er stand sogar ein bisschen zu lange.
Also er ist jetzt wirklich gut.
Ihr erkennt es auch daran:
Wenn ihr jetzt hier mit dem Finger mal reindrückt
und dieser Fingerabdruck wieder schön zurückspringt,
dann ist der Teig perfekt für den Backofen.
Jetzt gibt es verschiedene Möglichkeiten.
Ihr könnt jetzt, wenn ihr einen Dampfbackofen habt,
wirklich volle Dampfstufe benutzen.
Und das ist eigentlich auch so das Beste,
was ihr mit dem Brot machen könnt.
Denn auch in der Bäckerei, in der Profibäckerei
wird natürlich das Brot unter Schwaden gebacken,
also mit Dampfstoß.
Und wenn ihr einen Backofen habt, der das hat,
dann wirklich die ersten 10, 15 Minuten voller Dampf
– "voraus" wollte ich sagen.
Die ersten 10, 15 Minuten richtig mit Volldampf backen.
Später den Dampf entweichen lassen
und das Brot fertig backen, sodass es wirklich
eine schöne knusprige Kruste dann auch bekommt.
Oder die zweite Version
oder die zweite Möglichkeit wäre ein Gusseisentopf.
Der ist ja auch natürlich vom Material her sehr stark,
speichert die Wärme extrem gut
und er dient im Prinzip als Dampfbackofen.
Denn er hat hier an der Oberfläche diese Noppen.
Und jetzt stellt euch eines vor: Der Teig kommt hier rein.
Im Teig ist das ganze Wasser enthalten,
verdampft natürlich
und kondensiert hier an der Oberfläche an den Noppen.
Und so tropft das Wasser
dann wieder schön gleichmäßig auf das Brot zurück.
Das brauchen wir natürlich,
damit das Brot zum einen gut aufgeht,
und es wird einfach wunderwunderbar.
Viele sagen auch, dass man komplett ohne Dampfbackofen
und ohne Gusseisentopf backen kann
und praktisch eine Schale Wasser
in den Backofen reinschüttet, damit sich der Dampf bildet.
Dazu muss ich sagen:
Ich habe das mal gemacht vor langer Zeit.
Bei uns war das Problem:
Wir haben auch sehr kalkhaltiges Wasser.
Das heißt, ihr habt am Ende
eine Riesenschweinerei im Backofen, weil alles weiß ist,
und der Dampf ist halt nicht
– also man hat nicht so viel Dampf,
wie man eigentlich benötigt.
Von daher finde ich eigentlich die Dampfbackofen-
oder die Gusseisenversion so am besten.
Ihr könnt aber auch
– wenn ihr sagt, ihr habt beides nicht,
probiert es einfach ohne und das wird euch auch gelingen.
Aber es sind halt optimalere Ergebnisse,
wenn ihr optimale Bedingungen habt natürlich.
Was ich jetzt gemacht habe:
Ich habe den Gusseisentopf schon mal vorgeheizt,
damit der einfach nicht noch die Aufheizzeit hat.
Ich hole den kurz raus.
Vorsichtshalber einfach ein bisschen Backtrennspray.
Aber normalerweise löst sich Brot wirklich ganz gut,
wenn es super gebacken ist.
Und jetzt ganz vorsichtig sein.
Ihr habt das Brot mit Liebe zubereitet.
Passt aber jetzt auch auf eure Finger auf,
dass ihr euch nicht verbrennt.
Und in dem Moment denke ich mir so: Uh!
Und jetzt noch einschneiden am Rand.
Ich mache das jetzt hier.
Ihr könnt es aber einschneiden, wie ihr möchtet,
gern auch auf der Oberfläche.
Und jetzt sofort im Ofen heiß backen.
Ich starte jetzt erst mal bei 240°C,
stelle dann den Backofen nach zehn Minuten runter auf 200°C,
lasse den Deckel noch schön drauf.
Und später, wenn der Dampf sich praktisch
komplett gebildet hat im Gusseisentopf,
mache ich den Deckel runter
und möchte natürlich ohne Deckel weiter backen,
damit ich eine tolle Kruste habe.
Falls ihr jetzt ohne Gusseisentopf backt
und eben einen Dampfbackofen habt,
die ersten 10, 15 Minuten Volldampf
und dann einfach Dampf entweichen lassen und fertig backen.
Aber am Anfang immer erst mal eine höhere Temperatur
und dann runterschalten.
[Musik]
Jetzt kommt natürlich der große Moment.
Jetzt sehe ich, wie schön mein Brot geworden ist.
Ah! Es sieht super aus!
Guckt einmal.
Und es bekommt trotzdem schon eine schöne Kruste.
Und jetzt backe ich es aber noch fertig.
Und wie gesagt, ihr schaut einfach.
Je nach Backofen kann es sein,
dass ihr 15 Minuten vor Backende
praktisch den Deckel schon abnehmt
oder zehn Minuten vorher.
Wir wollen es auch nicht zu dunkel werden lassen.
Das müsst ihr wirklich ein bisschen individuell bestimmen
und nach euren eigenen Bedürfnissen
und nach eurem eigenen Backofen gehen.
Also ich backe es jetzt, glaube ich,
erst mal nur acht Minuten weiter,
weil es doch schon eine gute Farbe auch hat.
[Musik]
Jetzt ist es fertig gebacken.
Jetzt können wir mal reinschauen.
Es sieht echt super aus.
Und ihr könnt jetzt das Brot kontrollieren,
ob es komplett fertig ist.
Guck mal. Es löst sich auch perfekt.
Und zwar, wenn ihr an die Rückseite klopft
und es hört sich hohl an wie an so einer Zimmertür,
– herein –
dann ist es fertig.
Und ich nehme es jetzt aus dem Ofen raus.
Ich brauche einen zweiten Handschuh.
Ich nehme es jetzt aus dem Ofen raus
und werde es dann aber nicht im Topf abkühlen lassen,
sondern auf einem Abkühlgitter.
Denn, wenn ihr es jetzt im Topf abkühlen lasst,
dann habt ihr natürlich das Problem,
dass das Brot darin schwitzt,
und dann ist die schön gebackene Kruste wieder weg.
Also jetzt schön auf ein Abkühlgitter geben,
abkühlen lassen
und dann können wir es später probieren.
[Musik]
Das erste Brot ist jetzt fertig gebacken
und ihr habt gesehen, wie schnell es geht.
Jetzt möchte ich euch einfach in diesem restlichen Video
noch die anderen fünf Brotsorten zeigen.
Ich zeige euch einfach kurz, wie sie hergestellt werden,
beziehungsweise halte es relativ kurz.
Denn die Teigzubereitung ist im Prinzip
bei allen sechs Teigsorten gleich.
Und bei der Formgebung,
da kann ich euch einfach so ein paar Variationen zeigen.
Jetzt kommen wir hier direkt zu Brot zwei.
Und dieses Brot, das ist ein reines Dinkelbrot.
Und es besteht wirklich auch nur aus Dinkel,
das heißt keine Weizenbestandteile und auch kein Roggen.
Hier habe ich jetzt die Hauptzutaten mal aufgelistet.
Zum einen haben wir das Dinkelmehl.
Und ich muss auch sagen,
dass ich auch selbst beim Kuchenbacken
oder auch beim Brotbacken, beim Baguette,
eigentlich fast zu 90 Prozent
nur noch Dinkelmehl 630er verwende,
weil ich Dinkel erst mal vom Geschmack her super finde.
Und Dinkel hat halt auch den Vorteil:
Dinkel hat eine härtere Schale.
Das heißt, das Dinkelgetreide
ist wirklich von Umwelteinflüssen eher verschont
als jetzt Weizen oder Roggen,
weil es wirklich diese harte Schale hat.
Man hat aber dadurch natürlich auch bei der Zubereitung
oder bei der Verarbeitung den Nachteil,
dass es den Schälprozess eben auch erschwert.
Es ist ein zusätzlicher Aufwand
und deswegen ist Dinkelmehl eben auch generell teurer
als Weizen- oder Roggenmehl zum Beispiel.
Das vielleicht so zum Hintergrund.
Und man sagt ja auch gerade bei Urdinkel,
das ist ja auch eher so die bekömmlichere Variante
und ist eigentlich eine gute Alternative
für alle, die jetzt kein Weizen vertragen.
[Musik]
Schön sieht es aus.
Ihr seht, hier hat das Tuch so ein bisschen geklebt.
Also ihr könnt auch gern
auf die Oberfläche des Teiges ein bisschen Mehl geben,
damit es nicht klebt.
Was ich jetzt machen werde:
Ich zeige euch jetzt einmal, wie ich ein rundes Brot backe
und aber auch wie ich Brötchen mache.
Weil gerade das Dinkelbrot
eignet sich super zum Brötchenbacken.
Man muss aber trotzdem dazu sagen:
Es ist eine Brotbackmischung
und keine Brötchenbackmischung.
Von daher...
Aber gerade bei dem Dinkelbrot muss ich sagen,
eignet sich es echt gut.
Also jetzt machen wir die Hälfte so, die andere Hälfte so.
So. Die Hände leicht bemehlen.
Und wenn es natürlich komplett Dinkel bleiben soll,
dann natürlich Dinkelmehl benutzen und kein Weizenmehl.
Und jetzt einfach mit leicht bemehlten Händen
zu einer runden Kugel formen.
Und dabei darauf achten,
jetzt nicht so viel Mehl einzuarbeiten,
dass eben keine Mehlnester entstehen.
Und hier auch schön immer mit dem Handballen arbeiten,
von außen nach innen.
Dann umdrehen.
Kurz rund formen.
Jetzt könnt ihr es gerne hier in so einem Gärkörbchen
aufgehen lassen
oder einfach auf einem Tuch oder Backblech.
So.
Schön abdecken.
Und dann könnt ihr gerne eure Brötchen formen.
Da würde ich sie jetzt auf jeden Fall abwiegen.
Und je nachdem, wie groß ihr sie haben wollt,
würde ich sagen so 80 Gramm.
Ihr könnt sie aber auch kleiner machen
und 50 Gramm nur nehmen.
60.
60 ist auch gut.
Ich nehme 60.
Das war jetzt gerade ein Zeichen.
[Musik]
Und jetzt im Prinzip wie beim großen Brot
einfach von außen nach innen.
Und dann könnt ihr sie so rund formen.
Also ich habe ja den Teig jetzt ein bisschen weicher gemacht.
Natürlich ist da das Brötchenformen schwieriger.
Wenn man ein bisschen übt, geht es auch.
Also, wenn ihr von vornherein her schon wisst,
ihr macht Brötchen daraus,
dann macht ihn nicht ganz so weich.
Und hier nehmt ihr im Prinzip den Teig auf
und wollt ja die Oberfläche, dass sie eine Spannung hat.
Deswegen forme ich auch erst mal
alles von außen nach innen mit den Fingern,
drehe es dann um.
Und was ich hier mache
oder auch auf der Arbeitsplatte mache,
ist immer mit dem kleinen Finger und dem Daumen
einfach hier so rund formen.
Ja. Also hier habt ihr im Prinzip genau das Gleiche.
Manche
– also meine Mama hat sie immer in der Hand gemacht.
Ich habe es irgendwann auf der Arbeitsfläche gemacht.
Das müsst ihr einfach selber mal ausprobieren.
Und dann lasse ich das Brot
und auch die Brötchen noch kurz aufgehen
und kann sie dann anschließend backen.
[Musik]
Brot Nummer drei zeichnet sich
durch seinen hohen Ballaststoffanteil aus.
Ich habe hier zum einen das Roggenmehl,
ich habe aber auch den Roggenschrot
und ich habe hier die Leinsamen.
Die Leinsamen sind geschrotet in unserer Backvormischung,
sodass sie wirklich auch
vom Körper aufgenommen werden können.
Sie wirken sehr positiv auf die Verdauung,
sind natürlich auch reich an Omega-3-Fettsäuren.
Und wir haben das Brot dann hier noch verfeinert
mit diesen Gewürzen.
Ich habe jetzt hier, klar, Salz mit dabei,
aber ich habe auch meine Dreiermischung
an Kümmel, Fenchel und Anis
und haben die Dreiergewürzmischung einfach noch optimiert
durch die Koriandersamen.
Die passen einfach geschmacklich hervorragend dazu.
Ich zeige euch mal kurz die Hauptbestandteile des Brotes.
Wir haben hier zum einen das Roggenmehl,
das Weizenmehl,
Gerstenmalzmehl zur Farbbilder und auch zu Aromabildung,
Roggensauerteig,
Roggenschrot,
die Leinsamen
– die sind teilweise geschrotet, teilweise im Ganzen –
und hier noch die Gewürzmischung
aus Salz,
Fenchel,
Anis,
Kümmel
und Koriandersamen.
Und ihr seht es ja schon an den Zutaten.
Also das ist so ein Brot, was sehr roggenlastig ist.
Und es kommt auch typischerweise aus dem Odenwald.
Und deswegen haben wir es auch
mit in unser Brotsortiment aufgenommen,
weil es einfach schön kräftig, kernig ist
und eigentlich die Rezeptur genau so ist,
wie es früher die Hausmuttis eben auch im Odenwald
in einem Holzofen gebacken haben.
Daher ist es wirklich ein superwürziges und schönes Brot.
Dazu passt zum Beispiel Bergkäse perfekt dazu.
Und auch jetzt hier bei der Zubereitung ganz einfach:
Ihr nehmt die Brotvormischung.
Wir haben ja hier die Zutaten
praktisch für euch zusammengepackt,
alles schon vorgewogen.
Ihr gebt jetzt hier noch Wasser und eben die frische Hefe dazu.
[Musik]
So sieht der Teig super aus.
Und ihr könnt aus dem Teig
jetzt entweder ein rundes Brot formen
oder auch ein längliches Brot.
Ich habe mir jetzt überlegt, ich mache jetzt zwei kleine Brote,
das heißt zweimal 500-Gramm-Brote.
Ich kann das jetzt also hier halbieren.
Und ihr könnt die jetzt entweder frei formen
und dann aufgehen lassen
oder ihr könnt auch wieder Gärkörbe benutzen.
Also das dürft ihr einfach selber entscheiden.
Jetzt mit leicht bemehlten Händen
einfach erst mal zu einer Kugel formen.
[Musik]
Einfach mit der glatten Seite nach unten hier rein.
Meine Brote sind jetzt fertig gebacken und abgekühlt.
Ich schneide euch mal das eine hier an.
Da haut es die Packung noch von der Theke.
Es ist ja wirklich ein schönes ballaststoffreiches Brot.
Und ich finde es auch schön,
wenn man zwei kleine Brote backt.
Dann hat man kleinere Brotscheiben.
Und die könnt ihr euch dann schmecken lassen.
Ich muss auch sagen:
Samira und Ela schmecken sie auch sehr gut.
[Musik]
Brot Nummer vier ist ein dunkles Mehrkornbrot,
was, obwohl es ein Mehrkornbrot ist und dunkel ist,
eben trotzdem schön locker ist.
Und zwar haben wir das
zum einen mit Weizen- und Roggenmehl zubereitet
und wir haben hier noch Ölsaaten mit dabei.
Also Ölsaaten sind ja praktisch zum Beispiel Leinsamen,
aus denen man eben auch Leinöl gewinnen kann,
oder auch Sesam, Sesamöl
oder eben Sonnenblumenöl aus Sonnenblumen.
Und diese Vormischung ist so besonders,
weil man zum einen eben
dieses vollmundige, aromatische Brot hat,
aber zum anderen eben auch ein lockeres Brot,
also nicht so schwer.
Und gerade die Leinsaaten
oder die Ölsaaten insgesamt
verfeinern es eben wirklich super.
Die Hauptzutaten sind Roggenmehl,
Weizenmalzschrot,
Weizenmehl,
Weizengrießkleie
und Roggensauerteig.
Ich habe hier auch ein Gerstenröstmalz.
Hier habe ich noch verschiedene Ölsaaten,
also Leinsamen, Sesam und Sonnenblumenkerne,
Sojaschrot
und etwas Salz.
[Musik]
Bei diesem Brot mache ich es jetzt so
– ihr könnt das Ganze jetzt
entweder schön formen
und in einem Gärkorb aufgehen lassen
oder auch einfach frei auf einem Backblech aufgehen lassen.
So werde ich das jetzt machen.
Also ich mache da jetzt mal ein längliches Brot daraus.
Ich mache jetzt hier wieder mit dem Handballen
einfach hier außen so eine schöne, glatte Oberfläche.
Immer leicht bemehlen.
Und dann könnt ihr es gerne schon in die Form bringen.
Und wenn ihr möchtet,
könnt ihr auch gerne noch die Oberfläche befeuchten
und ein paar Ölsaaten oder Haferflocken oder Schrot
auf die Oberfläche mit drauf geben.
Schmeckt zum einen gut und sieht halt auch schön aus.
Ich habe mir hier einfach so eine Mischung gemacht
aus Haferflocken, Leinsamen, Sesam.
Das könnt ihr euch einmal vorbereiten
und immer wieder zum Brotbacken
oder auch einfach für Müsli benutzen.
Jetzt einfach schön reintauchen.
[Musik]
Auf dieses Brot freue ich mich jetzt ganz besonders.
Denn ich habe ja hier drumherum noch die Ölsaaten,
das heißt, die sind jetzt im Backofen
auch noch geröstet worden.
Bringt natürlich zusätzliches Aroma mit rein.
Also das könnt ihr machen, müsst ihr aber nicht.
Aber ich finde, es hat halt nicht nur den optischen,
sondern eben auch den geschmacklichen Vorteil.
Jetzt kurz ins Innere schauen.
Und ihr seht ja schon:
Obwohl ich es frei geformt habe ohne Gärkorb
und frei gebacken habe im Backofen,
ist es wunderschön geworden.
Also es kann wirklich jeder nachbacken.
Und auch im Inneren sieht es echt schön aus.
Und vor allem riecht es echt toll.
[Musik]
Brot Nummer fünf ist so ein richtiges Genussbrot,
was aus edlen Zutaten hergestellt und für uns gemischt wurde.
Und ich zeige euch mal kurz die Hauptzutaten.
Die drei Hauptzutaten sind das Roggenmehl,
das Kastanienmehl
und das Weizenmehl.
Wir haben es dann noch verfeinert mit dem Roggensauerteig,
mit Leinsamen und Sonnenblumenkernen,
mit Kürbiskernen,
mit dem Maisgrieß,
dem Schlütermehl,
dem Traubenkernmehl
und etwas Salz.
Gerade beim Kastanienmehl muss man dazu sagen:
Das Kastanienmehl wurde aus der Edelkastanie hergestellt
aus der italienischen Schweiz.
Da kommt es her.
Und gerade eine Kastanie,
die hat natürlich ein hohen Ölgehalt.
Und wir haben wirklich so viel Kastanienmehl wie möglich
in diese Brotmischung mit reingegeben.
Es gibt einen einzigartigen Geschmack, eine tolle Konsistenz.
Und gerade, wenn man am Kastanienmehl
selbst mal riecht, das riecht halt echt extrem gut.
Was wir hier noch mit dabei haben,
sind natürlich, klar, die Leinsamen,
die Sonnenblumenkerne und die Kürbiskerne,
die auch einen supertollen Geschmack,
aber eben auch eine tolle Konsistenz mit dazu geben.
Hier noch Maisgrieß,
weil gerade der Maisgrieß hier
für die Krume ganz besonders ist,
aber eben auch für die Farbgebung und für den Geschmack.
Das Schlütermehl, das ist eigentlich eine Roggenkleie,
die aus den Randschichten des Roggenkorns gewonnen wird.
Also wirklich keine Mehlbestandteile.
Und gerade in den Randschichten
da sitzen ja die ganzen Vitamine und Mineralstoffe.
Und deswegen ist dieses Schlütermehl echt ganz besonders.
Und was ich noch
– also das ist fast neben dem Kastanienmehl
so mein Highlight in diesem Brot,
nämlich das Traubenkernmehl.
Und gerade bei Traubenkernen weiß man ja:
Sie sind ballaststoffreich,
reich an sekundären Pflanzenstoffen.
Und was hier das Besondere ist,
dass die sekundären Pflanzenstoffe und die Inhaltsstoffe
beim Traubenkernmehl auch im gebackenen Zustand,
also auch wenn Hitze dran war, wirklich erhalten bleiben.
Das heißt, man hat hier wirklich
die ganzen Inhaltsstoffe des Traubenkernmehls
im Brot mit dabei.
[Musik]
Das Brot Nummer fünf könnt ihr übrigens
auch noch ganz toll verfeinern mit zum Beispiel Nüssen,
mit Äpfeln, mit Cranberries,
mit Zutaten, die euch einfach noch gut schmecken.
Ich werde jetzt den Teig schon mal verarbeiten,
das heißt, erst mal kurz verrühren,
dann zehn Minuten kneten
und kurz vor Ende der Knetzeit
gebe ich dann noch meine Extras mit dazu.
[Musik]
Deckel drauf und ab in den Backofen.
Das edle Brot Nummer fünf ist jetzt auch fertig.
Und man sieht auch direkt an der Oberfläche die Apfelstücke.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt,
ob ich gleich auch noch die Nüsse erwische.
Das wäre natürlich der Jackpot.
Jackpot!
Ach, guckt einmal!
So sieht doch ein leckeres Brot aus.
Ach, ist das schön!
[Musik]
Brot Nummer sechs ist ein Roggenmischbrot,
was sich durch die Kräuter und die Gewürze auszeichnet.
Also es ist wirklich schön aromatisch.
Und ich habe jetzt hier bewusst Gartenkräuter verwendet,
wie Rosmarin, Liebstöckel,
habe aber auch Gewürze mit dabei,
die ich jeden Tag so in meiner Küche benutze,
wie zum Beispiel Kurkuma und auch Ingwer.
Ich habe hier das Roggenmehl
mit dem Weizenmehl vermischt,
habe einen Roggensauerteig,
die Haferflocken
und Chia-Samen als Superfood dabei,
Gerstenröstmalz,
die Leinsamen und Sonnenblumenkerne
und hier noch die Gewürze und Kräuter,
zum einen Majoran,
Rosmarin,
Ingwer und Kurkuma,
Liebstöckel
und Salz.
Hier im Brot haben wir die Haferflocken und die Chia-Samen.
Haferflocken haben ja sowieso einen hohen Eiweißgehalt,
sorgen auch für den kernigen Biss im Brot.
Und die Chia-Samen, die gelten ja sowieso als Superfood,
also sind auch hier total ballaststoffreich und eiweißreich.
Das Gerstenröstmalz
bringt die natürliche Farbe des Brotes mit rein.
Und die Gartenkräuter sind eben superfein, weil
– also da haben wir es wirklich ganz schön ausgeklügelt
und einfach so das perfekte Verhältnis
von Kräutern und Gewürzen mitgenommen,
sodass es eben schön aromatisch schmeckt,
aber auch nicht zu dominant ist.
Also das Brot ist trotzdem ein schön würziges Brot,
was aber eben auch zu allem passt.
Und gerade Rosmarin, Majoran und Liebstöckel
sind echt so Gewürze,
die ich beim Kochen sehr gerne benutze
und die aber auch perfekt zum Brot passen.
Gerade Liebstöckel, wirklich ein ganz, ganz tolles Gewürz.
Und die Ölsaaten habe ich jetzt hier auch,
habe die Leinsamen mit dabei und die Sonnenblumenkerne,
die eben auch, wenn man das Brot aufschneidet,
einfach ein schönes optisches Bild ergeben.
[Musik]
Ich habe jetzt den Topf vorgewärmt
und kann jetzt den Teig reinsetzen.
Jetzt könnt ihr im Prinzip überlegen,
ob ihr diese Seite oben möchtet
oder diese.
Ich glaube, ich will es jetzt einmal so rum,
weil ich es echt schön finde.
Ich glaube, so bekommt das Brot eine tolle Optik.
Und jetzt wieder schön verschließen
und backen.
Und ihr seht: Brotbacken ist so gar kein Hexenwerk.
So sieht das fertige Brot jetzt aus.
Ich finde es wirklich wunderwunderschön
und vor allem auch mit der Oberfläche.
Also ich glaube, das mache ich öfter,
dass ich einfach die Naht nach oben lege,
weil es einfach eine tolle Oberfläche gibt.
Also echt wunderbar!
Jetzt wird es noch kurz angeschnitten.
Ta-daa!
Also ganz ehrlich,
also ich muss echt sagen:
Das Brot riecht wunderbar,
nicht zu intensiv,
also obwohl wir die Gartenkräuter und Gewürze
mit dabei haben, nicht zu intensiv.
Da kann ich mir jetzt ganz gut ein bisschen Butter
oder einfach Olivenöl dazu vorstellen.
Mehr braucht ein gutes Brot auch eigentlich gar nicht.
Also ich denke, wenn man Brote gerne viel belegt,
ist es vielleicht deswegen,
weil die Brote an sich nicht so gut schmecken
oder eben keinen Eigengeschmack haben.
Und so kann man wirklich sagen:
Alle sechs Brote und besonders auch hier das sechste hier
hat wirklich ein ganz, ganz tollen Geschmack.
Hier seht ihr jetzt meine Brote, die ich heute gebacken habe.
Und ich muss sagen, jedes Brot ganz individuell hergestellt
hat einen ganz besonderen eigenen Geschmack.
Und ich finde es einfach toll,
dass wir das Projekt so realisieren konnten.
Zum einen konnten wir ein paar Arbeitsplätze schaffen.
Denn auch das Abfüllen der Brotvormischungen
in diese besonderen Verpackungen
ist natürlich auch Handarbeit,
jetzt auch gerade dieses Zusammennähen.
Also wir haben uns wirklich von Anfang bis zum Ende
ganz viele Gedanken gemacht, viel Mühe gemacht
und geschaut, was wir wo
nachhaltig natürlich auch herstellen können.
Und ich denke, dass so jeder mit so einer Brotvormischung
sein eigenes Brot zu Hause nachbacken kann,
ohne großen Aufwand.
Ihr habt ja auch gesehen:
Die Arbeitszeit beträgt maximal zwölf Minuten.
Also zehn Minuten Teig kneten.
Ob es dann die Küchenmaschine macht
oder ihr mit euren Oberarmen macht,
ist ja dann im Prinzip zweitrangig.
Dann habt ihr nur noch das Brotformen
und der Rest ist eigentlich nur noch die Wartezeit.
Und von Anfang bis zum Ende
sind es wirklich maximal zwei Stunden.
Und ihr habt innerhalb von zwei Stunden
euer eigenes Brot zu Hause gebacken.
Ja.
Eigentlich relativ simpel und einfach,
ohne großartige Werkzeuge oder Gegenstände.
Das kann, glaube ich, jeder machen.
Was ihr vielleicht noch beachten solltet:
Also auch die Richtwerte,
die ich auf der Verpackung angegeben habe,
wie Backofen, die Heizart, die Backtemperatur
und natürlich auch die Backzeit,
sind natürlich ganz individuell.
Probiert es einfach bei eurem Backofen zu Hause aus.
Das Ganze sind Richtwerte.
Ihr könnt euch ja wirklich auch auf eure Sinne verlassen.
Also wirklich das Brot oder den Teig
bis zur vollen Reife eben gären lassen,
den Fingerdrucktest machen,
das Brot aus dem Backofen nehmen,
wenn sich es auf der Unterseite hohl anhört,
und natürlich dann auch das Brot
einfach auf einem Abkühlgitter abkühlen lassen,
sodass die Kruste so lange wie möglich schön knusprig bleibt.
Wenn ihr das Brot dann angeschnitten habt
und es mehrere Tage
– falls es so lange hält bei euch –
mehrere Tage dann zu Hause verstauen wollt,
dann legt es am besten auf die Schnittkante auf ein Holzbrett,
lasst es so in der Küche stehen.
Und dann habt ihr wirklich jeden Tag einen schönen Anschnitt,
der eben so auch nicht austrocknen kann.
Und ansonsten würde ich sagen:
Brote eignen sich auch super zum Einfrieren.
Aber ich glaube,
dass die so lecker sind,
dass sie wahrscheinlich gar nicht dazu reichen,
dass man sie einfriert.
Außer ihr seid ein recht kleiner Haushalt,
alleine.
Denn bei uns sind sie relativ schnell leer.
Ich hoffe, dass ich euch mit diesem Video
ein paar Brotbacktipps geben konnte
und euch unser neues Projekt gefällt.
Lasst mir gerne euer Feedback da.
Falls ihr das Brot schon ausprobiert habt,
dann schreibt es mir auch gerne in die Kommentare.
Und wenn ihr eins dieser sechs Brotsorten nachbackt,
dann postet es gerne unter dem Hashtag #sallysbrote.
Da sehe ich nämlich eure Ergebnisse.
Und wer weiß?
Also wir haben schon ganz viele neue Ideen
auch mit dem Peter entwickelt.
Das heißt, wenn es bei euch gut ankommt,
wenn es euch gefällt, das ganze Brotprojekt,
dann machen wir auch gerne weitere Sorten,
würden dann auch das Thema erweitern
in Richtung Brötchen backen
und können so im Prinzip unsere Brotvielfalt erweitern.
Also vielen Dank fürs Zuschauen!
Und bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss!
[Musik]